a lot of folks are understandably ready
to pull the plug on 2016 but before you
pop the champagne here are five things
libertarians should be nervous about in
the new year at a time when most
Americans support legalization 2017
could be bad news for those in favor of
legal weed though Trump has said
legalization should be up to the states
he's been appointing anti marijuana
lawmakers to key positions in his
cabinet the most notable of these is
Alabama Senator Jeff Sessions he's been
tapped as Attorney General sessions has
long opposed legalization and has
criticized both the Obama administration
and the Department of Justice for not
enforcing federal marijuana laws I mean
we need grown-ups in charge in
Washington decide marijuana is not the
kind of thing that ought to be legalized
when Donald Trump is sworn into office
he'll be inheriting a debt that has
nearly doubled under President Obama in
early 2017 the national debt is set to
hit a staggering 20 trillion dollars but
don't expect the new administration to
make America's fiscal nightmare great
again estimates from the committee for a
responsible budget say Trump's policy
proposals will add another 5.3 trillion
dollars over the next four years
globalization and free trade have lifted
millions out of poverty and raise living
standards across the United States yeah
we enter 2017 with both Democrats and
Republicans questioning the fundamental
value of free markets a new
administration promising to inject
itself into the affairs of private
companies and a president openly
threatening a costly trade war with
China
it's now clear that so-called faint news
can have real-world consequences those
consequences now include Facebook
testing new plugins to limit
misinformation and partnering with
fact-checking groups to read out any
false news items causing fears of
censorship on the popular social media
platform when policymakers and
politicians start pressuring private
companies to limit speech expect trouble
the FBI NSA and CIA are most likely
going to get shiny new surveillance
powers under a trump administration now
some of these changes are already
happening a new rule approved this fall
allows federal agents with a single
search warrant to hack millions of
Americans computers or smartphones at
once and it's not just Uncle Sam the
United Kingdom just approved the
investigatory powers bill which gives
the UK's global surveillance program
authorities power to create a new
government database that will store the
web history of every citizen in the
country so by all means say goodbye to
2016 but don't let your guard down
there'll be plenty to be nervous about
in the new year
[Music]